c'est dans cette école des trois ilets
que l'ennemi aurait dû passer des
vacances inoubliables
entouré de nombreux autres enfants pour
la plupart plus âgés que lui
le petit garçon à quatre ans et demi il
est certes un peu turbulent alors son
papa prend bien soin d'expliquer aux
animateurs du centre aéré qu'il faut
absolument le protéger du soleil
tous les matins dans le sac de lenny il
met de la crème solaire et son tee shirt
anti uv mais l'enfant revient avec
plusieurs coups de soleil jeudi dernier
c'était jour de bataille d'eau prévoyant
le papa tartine lui-même son fils de
crème solaire lui enfile son tee shirt
protecteur dès le matin et alerte les
animateurs ça me semblait logique étant
donné que c'était une journée bataille
d'eau et qui avait déjà préalablement
aussi un coup de soleil de 2,2 pas lui
retirer son ne pas durcir son son tee
shirt
donc si au cas où il lui le retirer
soyez vigilante
remettez lui tout simplement donc je
récupère au soir du touch son épaule et
j'entends à papa papa et j'ai un fils
qui a une très bonne tolérance à la
douleur donc là je me suis posé comme
tout de suite des questions j'ai levé
son tee shirt j'ai vu des cloques un
pédiatre vue le soir même confirme qu'il
s'agit d'un très fort coup de soleil
mais le lendemain l'état de ligny
s'aggrave encore aux urgences de la mfm
cette fois on lui découvre des brûlures
au second degré aux épaules et entre les
omoplates
là où je suis très très en colère c'est
que c'est pas l'unique à retirer 100
t-shirts
ce sont des tati
le père de lenny compte écrire au
procureur de la république
il a bien sûr contacter les responsables
de la fo elle la fédération des oeuvres
laïques organisatrice du centre aéré sur
place ce matin personne n'a été autorisé
à nous répondre
face caméra mais on nous a expliqué
prendre cet incident très au sérieux
une enquête interne est lancé dès
aujourd'hui pour déterminer si oui ou
non il y avait eu négligence et les
assurances de la fo elle devrait entrer
en jeu en cas de besoin espérons juste
que les vacances du petit lait ni se
termineront mieux qu'elles n'ont
commencé sans séquelles psychologiques
ou physiques